it's great to see you all here tonight
and it's a real pleasure for me to
introduce our tonight speaker if I were
to attempt to regale you with all of his
accomplishments there would be no time
for his presentation so I'm going to try
and summarize them here very briefly and
give you enough background to show the
credibility of what he's going to speak
to us tonight about General Grant
Josiah Bunning is well known to many of
you if not personally at least through
his reputation as an educator and author
following his graduation from VMI in
1963 and his completion of his studies
as a Rhodes Scholar he joined the United
States Army and completed six years of
distinguished service at Fort Bragg with
the 9th Infantry Division in Vietnam and
with the United States Military Academy
is an associate professor of history and
social studies after leaving the
military academy he joined the faculty
of the United States Army Naval War
College Nathan Naval War College ok
before becoming named president of
Briarcliff college in upstate New York
in 1973 he remained at Briarcliff until
1977 and then he became the president of
the Hampton Sydney College a men's
college southeast of Richmond Virginia
for the next 10 years in 1987 he became
the headmaster of the Lawrenceville
school an independent boarding school
near Princeton New Jersey and in 1995 he
became the thirteenth superintendent of
VMI his alma mater where he was charged
with the incident by the Institute's
governing board with implementing the
ruling of the United States Supreme
Court to integrate female cadets no
small challenge throughout his career as
an educator he's continued to develop
and teach courses at each of the
institutions he's led and he's become a
prolific novelist among as many works
among his many works are the lion heads
in 1973 the advent of Frederick Giles in
1974 and education for our time in 1998
and all loves excelling in 2001 he holds
honorary degrees from a number
for several colleges and as a member of
numerous honor societies and as a
trustee of med many educational
institutions he's married to the former
Diana Margaret Cunningham of Lima Peru
they have four children Josiah the
fourth Charles VMI graduate no.1
Elizabeth and Alexandra and they now
live in Newport Rhode Island sighs here
to share his insight to our 18th
president so please join me in welcoming
thank you
thank you all very much its I cannot
tell you what an honor and a pleasure
and a delight to be here I spent about
25 minutes being all but undressed by
the security apparatus of the War
College and finally was was allowed in
I'm looking forward to my visit tomorrow
to the Institute for military history
perhaps the same procedure will be
observed over there I also would like at
the beginning to thank Sam Lombardo who
gave me a copy of his World War two book
World War two is very much on the mind
as many of you know of the generation
one or two steps below ours that is to
say young people between the ages of 15
and 25 they are close to their
grandparents many of their grandparents
are in their 80s they are very much
aware of that generation in particular
think just for a moment that the United
States between 1940 and 1945 had a
population of a hundred and thirty
million of whom 16 million in 1945 were
in uniform and they were led by what is
without a doubt the most capable
generation field officers and general
officers I think in the history of the
army a remarkable legacy I think one of
the things that commends that generation
in particular Sam Lombardo your
generation to this much younger
generation is their modesty they use a
phrase I hear it once or twice a year
that has gone almost out of fashion and
that is the phrase when they're asked
what they did in the war they say simply
I was in the service
I was in the service and of course of my
country is implied but it's not stated
and they leave it at that and then you
find out six months or two years or
three years later how distinguished and
how brave that service actually was well
I want to talk this evening briefly
about a very interesting and widely
misunderstood American my time is fair
the limited so I'm going to move along
quite quickly you know in the United
States we have a habit of rediscovering
for odd reasons forgotten heroes poets
generals ambassadors presidents usually
something happens which makes us think
about comparisons in earlier history and
that's something of all things about two
months ago was the publication of the
memoirs of Bill Clinton early reviewers
casting about for other books that they
could compare Clinton's memoirs to
particularly with regard to length hit
upon the famous memoirs of Ulysses Grant
those books do have certain things in
common perhaps most importantly is the
fact that each author wrote every word
himself and indeed both of these books
are very long the comparison ends rather
abruptly at that point however for a
number of reasons chiefly that Ulysses
Grant's memoirs widely regarded as one
of the great classics in the language a
great classic of American culture and
history
those are memoirs written after Grant
was president written in fact during the
time he was dying of a particularly
virulent cancer a race against time to
finish these memoirs a book devoted
almost entirely to his recollection of
his boyhood and after his boyhood is
explored his years at West Point he
devotes the rest of the book to an
exploration of the Mexican War and the
Civil War and his role in it early
reviewers in looking at grant go go
themselves through the process of
rediscovering the riches of that
particular book it is compared widely to
the memoirs of Julius Caesar the
commentaries of Julius Caesar it has
attracted writers and scholars as
different from each other as Matthew
Arnold and Gertrude Stein and Edmund
Wilson one of the interesting things
about Grant's memoirs is the fact
that ulysses grant like all deeply
honest instinctively honest people in
painting a picture of his own experience
and particularly of his recollection of
other people in the civil war on both
sides and of the Mexican war almost
unconsciously is presenting a picture of
himself as an extraordinary human being
a man of great modesty a man of enormous
skill a man of unfailing composure and
here is a word for you a man of great
chivalry it's almost as though he heeded
the advice that Mark Twain gave a friend
of his who proposed to write memoirs
Mark Twain said to John hey if you're
going to write an autobiography or write
memoirs remember this one thing no
matter what you do your facts and your
fictions will cooperate loyally together
for the protection of the reader
it's a daunting advice when you stop a
stop to think about it
General Grant didn't really need that
advice but many other people who write
memoirs do well we have a wonderful
memory of grant and it leads us briefly
to consider some of the things he said
in those memoirs let me say something
first about the fact the grant one of
those misunderstood characters is widely
saluted like many graduates of the
Military Academy as having been quote
unquote a mediocre cadet it's almost
like a line in a Homeric epithet he
graduated in the middle of his class he
was a mediocre cadet etc etc he was not
a mediocre cadet he was an extraordinary
student at the academy he matriculated
in 1839 graduated in 1843 he was
interested in four things horses
mathematics
would you believe oil painting and
sketching and finally prose prose
fiction he talks in his memoirs about
what he read when he was not so when he
was not doing the things the authorities
expected of him
all of James Fenimore Cooper Walter
Scott Edward bulwer-lytton cat
mariette he was a beautifully educated
young person who at the age of 17 or 18
already wrote a confident and beautiful
and limber prose style let me give you
three examples of what he says in the
memoir and then settled down to a quick
assessment of general Grant's character
this is a very typical grant writing
these are very brief excerpts but I
think you will enjoy them here he's
comparing Abraham Lincoln who was his
great hero to Edwin Stanton who was
Secretary of War during most of the
Civil War whom Grant did not
particularly care for but whom he always
loyally served quote and in think about
this momentarily as a little bit of a
commentary on leadership mr. Lincoln
gained influence over other men by
making them feel that it was a pleasure
to serve him he always preferred
yielding his own wish to gratify others
rather than insisting on having his own
way it distressed mr. Lincoln to
disappoint others in matters of public
duty however he had what he wanted but
in the least offensive way mr. Stanton
cared nothing for the feeling of others
in fact it was pleasant her to him to
disappoint them than to gratify them and
yet mr. Lincoln was not timid and he was
willing to trust his generals in making
and executing their plans secretary
Stanton was very timid and it was
impossible for him to avoid interfering
with the armies he could see our
weakness but he could never see the
enemy's dangerous the enemy would not
have been in danger
if mr. Stanton himself had been in the
field that's a
that is a fairly typical grant
assessment are compassionate mild but
with a little hook towards the end here
grant comments on book learning and on
the obsessive attention being paid to
military history and strategy by some of
his colleagues by generals such as for
example Halleck quote these generals
were always thinking about what Napoleon
and Frederick the Great would do
unfortunately for them the rebels were
always thinking of something else
and finally and famously
and more seriously the writer remembers
Appomattox the most important hour or 90
minutes probably in American history
whatever General Lee's feelings they
were entirely concealed from my own
observation but my own feelings which
had been quite jubilant on the receipt
of his letter now became sad and
depressed
I felt like anything rather than
rejoicing at the downfall of a foe who
had fought so long and so valiantly and
suffered so much for a cause though that
cause was I believe one of the worst for
which a people ever fought this is a
famous quotation and it's very
characteristic of the way General Grant
judges people compassionate sympathetic
but at the same time honest you remember
I think probably from your own history
that when Andrew Johnson proposed to
allow the trial the projected trial of
General Lee and general Longstreet
general Joe Johnston and others to go
forward in Norfolk Virginia two months
after the war grant went to the
president and said if you do that I will
resign my commission I will not I will
not permit that Grant grew up in
southwestern Ohio in many respects he
was a southerner by sympathy if not by
conviction obviously he was a strong
Union man obviously he came to a
dominate slavery but the part of Ohio
where he grew up in a kind of an idyllic
boyhood from our perspective was a part
of the state that was settled basically
by southerners from the North Carolina
and Tennessee Piedmont
if you look at grant's career subsequent
to this at West Point in the Mexican War
and particularly after the Civil War his
natural friendships tented to drift in
the direction of Westerners and of
course in those days Iowa excuse me Ohio
was known as the West and southerners in
fact Longstreet became best man in the
grants wonderful wedding wedding that
lasted in a great marriage for some 45
years
well historians have handled Grant very
roughly and there are certain reasons
for that I want to talk about them just
just briefly the American clarity to use
an old-fashioned word that is to say the
American intellectual class journalists
pundits professors was as alive and is
rambunctious in the 1870s as they are
today and for the most part these were
men who cordially disliked General Grant
there are a number of reasons for this
there was a great cultural chasm between
the way they were educated when I talk
about this group of men I'm thinking
particularly of Boston Massachusetts and
New York in Philadelphia which were the
centers of cultural influence in those
days they had imputed to General Grant
when he became president during that
three-month period between the election
in the inauguration an extraordinary
array of qualities they had seen him as
a general they knew that he was
personally modest they knew that he was
disinterested that is to say objective
they knew he had won the war and they
imagined he could be a great president
and be a great president very quickly
not only would they be not only would he
be a great president but he would
appoint some of them to high ranking
posts in Europe but this he failed to do
and they never forgave him for it and
these people for the most part good men
and true including people like Henry
Adams became the lineal descendants of
most people who have written
about General Grant since 1885 when he
died it's interesting to look at how
succeeding generations have treated this
particular American president they have
tended invariably to reflect the biases
of his own time the three adjectives
three words that cling tenaciously to
Ulysses Grant one of them is drunk one
of them is butcher and the last one is
scandalmonger and he is almost
completely innocent
I can tell you of all three of those
charges and yet they come up again and
again and again and for example
historians writing between 1915 and 1930
concentrate on Grant as a quote unquote
butcher as a man who was prodigal in the
expenditure of human life
they are obviously writing against a
background of what has happened in
France on the Western Front the very
phrase presided over presided over the
most corrupt administration in American
history is something also that dates
from that particular time well the
period of grant's presidency 1869 to
1877 occurs right in the middle of one
of the great longers we would call it of
American history a period of 35 or 40
years about which most Americans know
very little and about which your sons
and daughters alas may know less than
little and I'm thinking particularly of
the presidencies of Grant's successors
and Grant himself
Garfield Arthur Hays those those kinds
of people about whom our culture has
been ignorant for a long time Thomas
Wolfe the novelist referred to them and
they're gravely vacant bewildered faces
man is ponderous and uninspiring as the
Gilded Age in which they lived we tend
to forget that Ulysses Grant at the
beginning of that age was given probably
the most difficult task ever given an
American president were the conceivable
exceptions of course of Abraham Lincoln
and Franklin Roosevelt namely presiding
over reconstruction guaranteeing that
the results of the Civil War
somehow could be met what was Ulysses
Grant like what was he like what were
the essential qualities of his
temperament and his character and his
intellect where did they come from how
did they serve him so well as a general
in much less well as a president emerson
called abraham lincoln a quite
Aboriginal american he used the term
advisedly and we might call grant a
quite Aboriginal using the term in the
same spirit a quite Aboriginal mid
Westerner I can see him crouching on
Utah Beach as a National Guard infantry
colonel reassuring the sons of friends
from the office entirely mission
oriented without pretense competent in a
quiet way handy with things practical
self-reliant quiet in speech
unpretentious he was in fact perhaps
more than any American general officer
in our history ideally suited to the
command of soldiers in war particularly
to the leadership of American
non-professionals draftees young
American citizens charged to his care
there are several reasons for this they
are to be found mainly in the boyhood of
grant in the circumstances of his
boyhood he was a quiet youngster he was
the eldest of seven children
he was diffident he was shy his father
was successful but was the town braggart
Ulysses very quickly developed the
protective coloration of doing things on
his own and doing them quietly and
perhaps out of shyness refusing to ask
for help you can see in embryo those
qualities that come to the fore in 1861
and 1862 when Lincoln finally discovers
that out west there is a general officer
who has achieved some success with his
soldiers and does it simply by saying
what I want is to attack I don't ask for
anything other than what I have to work
with
secondly as a general grant was a
complete servitor of the mission
assigned to him entirely self-reliant
hugely but modestly self-reliant with a
calm confidence that the decisions he
made somehow would be successfully
obeyed and would lead to victory it's
very close to use another literary
reference if you will indulge me in one
- what the poet Keats called
negative capability that is to say you
give yourself so entirely to the mission
and to the work that you scour away all
calculations of personal advantage you
simply do what it is necessary to do he
reminds us in some respects of Omar
Bradley when I think of grant and I try
to think of an American soldier who by
temperament and by the way he presents
himself to his soldiers and to others he
reminds me a great deal of Bradley a
calm unhurried easily worn competence of
the sort that radiates quietly and
encourages confidence this is a
resourcefulness that does not call
attention to itself again it is easy to
see where it came from
grant early in the Civil War served as a
civilian they turned to him in the
little town of Galena as soon as the the
news of Fort Sumter had had reached the
city and they asked him if he would help
in drilling the local militia he did
that he followed them to a camp in
Springfield and there he made himself
useful useful in a number of menial
capacities until finally the governor of
Illinois saying to a friend of his why
is General Grant so quiet excuse me why
is Ulysses Grant so quiet and the friend
said the way to get Ulysses Grant to do
something is simply to tell him to go
ahead and do it in virtually every
single important battle of the Civil War
from the early battle at Belmont through
Shiloh and Chattanooga and later in the
wilderness in Virginia there is a moment
invariably a quiet
there was nothing of the of the gaudy or
grand about grant in which something he
says or something he does literally
turns the tide of battle the most famous
example of this of course is the
conversation he has with his great
friend Sherman at ten o'clock on the
evening of the first day of Shiloh just
to refresh your memory the Battle of
Shiloh occurred in April 1862 combined
casualties on both sides aggregated a
number larger than all American dead and
wounded up until that time in our
national history Shiloh was a tragic
tragic battle Sherman came up to grant
and said we've had the devil's own time
of it grant and grant looked at him
quietly and said so we have lick him
tomorrow though he had this sense
somehow that he was able to communicate
to the people that work for him that the
things we work out like Julius Caesar
and Harry Truman to use an odd couple
grants character under wrote a calm and
efficient orderly we should say
methodical way of getting through
business a young writer called Horace
Porter who was one of grant's aides
during the war wrote a book called
campaigning with Grant he talks about
grant in the way he worked he was one of
these people who could perform many
tasks at the same time one after the
other were they fast but somehow
unhurried precision and with a judgement
unclouded from one task to the other
all-important military leaders who have
been successful in wartime have this
particular skill I think for example of
George Marshall whom I mentioned earlier
of Lord Allen Brooke Marshalls
equivalent in England somehow you get up
you go to work and you know that you
have 37 big things to do that day not
counting all of the things that will
burst burst in on your schedule and you
can move from one thing to the other
without any cloudy or enervating or
unhappy carryover from what you have
just been through grant had that
the loose lucid nosov his written
directives and his orders are a direct
testimony to a clear and orderly mine as
far as danger was concerned we talked
about this this evening at our table
grant was neither cowardly nor brave he
was indifferent to danger people noticed
that in situations where he was under
constant fire sometimes sitting on a
horse writing notes people noticed that
he somehow seemed indifferent to what
went on around him at the same time and
I think this is probably a good place to
mention this grant as president
15 years later got into trouble simply
because he lacked what we might harshly
call the moral courage to make very
tough decisions involving his own
colleagues and friends a man of
transcendent courage in battle found
himself in a political situation
embarrassed to find whatever it was
taken whatever it takes to make those
kinds of decision grants great English
contemporary was the Prime Minister of
England William Ewart Gladstone and he
said a prime requisite of a good Prime
Minister is to be a good pitcher a good
butcher and grant was not a good butcher
in a political sense jealous
contemporaries and historians have
called grant a butcher in battle in
combat if you have a chance there is a
new book coming out in the next 2 or 3
weeks on this very topic what were
grants losses they were immense of
course but what were they in comparison
to the number of people engaged given
the military technology of the period
just to remind you to refresh your
memories total casualties on both sides
during the Civil War combat death and
death of wounds 698 thousand and adding
in the wounded who did not die the
number approaches one and a half million
this was in a country a combined country
of 31 millions the butcher's bill today
if I may use that phrase in a country
of 298 million would be 5.4 million so
think of the casualties in the slaughter
suffered at that time two other things
all during grants military career
beginning at West Point Grant was
particularly suspicious of military what
he called rigmarole punctilious ness he
did not like creases and barked commands
and shiny boots and that kind of thing
and soon in one of his early assignments
he found a role-model who shared his
view of military smartness namely
Zachary Taylor if you're looking for a
role model or a hero for Ulysses Grant
surely he would be excuse me your best
possible example if grant had been a
baseball player he would have been a
catcher he would have been a catcher let
me tell you a quick anecdote about
College Admissions which is very much on
point all of you have children or
grandchildren who are going through the
rigmarole of trying to get into
expensive and famous universities here's
a nice story about somebody trying to do
that this occurred several years ago a
Dean of Admissions from Yale University
was visiting a very expensive and very
famous and very demanding boarding
school in New England and this
particular school had sent ten
applicants to Yale University this Dean
of Admissions walked around and looked
at the school met a number of students
watched some athletic events and then
when he looked at all of the files of
the ten people who had applied he
admitted number one two and ten turning
down number three through nine the
father was ecstatic the child was happy
beyond all expression and when he
matriculated in New Haven a few months
later the father went up to this Dean of
Admissions and said why did you take my
son we're thrilled but we're a little
bit they're puzzled well the Dean of
Admissions said I walked around long
enough to get something of a sense of
what kind of a young man he was and then
I looked at his record and I noticed
three things immediately
he was catcher on the baseball team he
was the goalie on your hockey team and
he played Center on the football team
and I thought to myself in all sports
these are the positions from which
leadership is most quietly and
authentically exerted where very little
credit is done where the risks are the
greatest and where the people who are
successful are rarely applauded isn't
that the kind of young man we want in
this college unfortunately it doesn't
work that with that that well as often
as we would like well finally grant as
president and just quickly grant is seen
and remembered primarily as General
Grant and as a president who had an
unsuccessful in trouble time in office
he was the same man he was the same man
in both positions he had the same
qualities of character in both positions
but of all things steadfastness of
commitment of commitment solemnly made
steadfastness of commitment to
friendships these were the kinds of
things that could make you a successful
and admired and even beloved general in
the Army in politics it doesn't work
quite that well Grant had an instinctive
sympathy for underdogs he was the
steadfast and loyal champion of
reconstruction at a time when most
people were abandoning that goal that
goal in fact was abandoned when
President Hayes succeeded Ulysses Grant
in 1877 he had a particularly strong
commitment for the American Indian there
is a single stark sentence that sticks
out in his first inaugural address in
which he vows that he will improve the
plight or the lot of the original
inhabitants of this land a larger moment
no president since Lyndon Johnson or
until Lyndon Johnson did more to assure
the results of the Civil War the end of
slavery in the achievement of full
citizenship and the franchise by black
Americans interestingly and you should
remember this if you're interested in
American politics the Republican Party
until 1930 or 1932
who was the party which was the natural
home of African Americans African
Americans many of them kept pictures of
Abraham Lincoln and in Ulysses Grant of
course was the guarantor of that result
of the of the Civil War think again if
you are Republicans or Democrats the
Republican Party was the natural home of
the african-american it was the party
that abominated deficits and it was the
party that did not get itself involved
in overseas adventures it was also the
party interestingly of the early stages
of the environmental movement
grant incidentally would have found
talking about grant and how he lived the
way we live now in our frantic pace of
work in our compulsion to be busy all
the time and particularly to be visible
visibly bitty of busy grant would have
found that ridiculous and farcical grant
went to the office at 10 o'clock every
morning after having a quiet breakfast
with his beloved wife Julia he worked
for approximately five hours the cabinet
met once a week and at three o'clock he
closed the office and went to his
stables at the end of his first three
months in office he left Washington to
go to Long Branch New Jersey where he
spent the summers he wrote a quick
letter to his sister saying the money is
being collected satisfactorily this is
policy enough for the present now we can
laugh at that the Victorians did not
laugh at that
that was their idea of how to live and
who is to say we are notably more
successful than they are Henry Adams are
cruelly said of grant and I have grants
presidency that to go from Alexander the
Great to Caesar to George Washington to
Ulysses Grant is to is to definitively
disprove Darwin that is a very that is a
very crude and cruel judgment but it's
memorable along with other anti grant
cracks such as taken to see the mounted
statue of Marcus Aurelius
he'll like the horse or the statement
imputed to grant on his famous
round-the-world trip namely Venice is a
beautiful city if they would drain the
streets we hear these things and we have
to remind ourselves that it may be grant
who is getting the last laugh on us well
finally and I talked about this briefly
a moment ago loyalty loyalty is a
principle of conduct this probably
characterizes Brandt as a person more
fully than anything else and loyalty is
the principle of conduct is contingent
that is to say it must be given to
people and principles who is worthiness
as objects of loyalty transcends the
mission to be discharged grants
fundamental weakness as president in his
second term especially was his
constitutional unwillingness to fire
people and here we come to the issue and
the question of scandals which I will
not dwell on but my book talks a little
bit about those kinds of things that
went on in the grant administration most
of which went on without grants
knowledge and when grant was told about
them he frequently learned about them in
disbelief and was extremely reluctant to
fire subordinates all good presidents it
seems to me can learn certain things
from grant one is what David Riesman the
sociologists would call inner
directedness that is to say fasten your
idealism upon certain things that you
believe in very deeply and hang on to
them for all you're worth we can
certainly learn that from Ulysses Grant
we can also learn it seems to me one of
the lessons that we learn from Ronald
Reagan that intellectual 'ti as
expressed as it expresses itself in
great and continuous verbal competence
is not necessarily the mark of a great
president if you want to look at the
history of the American presidency
remembering the remark that the cruel
remarked that somebody made about grant
look at the opening generation the first
administration which in
fluted Madison Jefferson Hamilton and
Washington in which when it needed
advice could go to the House of
Representatives and talk to James
Madison and talk to Benjamin Franklin we
don't it seems to me have that kind of
talent running for public office these
days but we have the next best thing
which is steadfast in loyal people who
believe deeply in things that are
willing to stand by them it is the final
final irony of Ulysses Brandt's career
it seems to me that his presidency which
was a noble effort which failed
frequently but which was steadfast has
been lost sight of basically because his
generalship was so good was so famous
and is so often it seems to me the
subject of studies by students here at
the Army War College I'm very grateful
to have the chance to talk to you and I
would be willing to entertain any
questions that you might have about
Ulysses Grant
thank you
yes yes the question has to do with
brands drinking was he a heavy drinker
no he was not
Grint drank during periods of loneliness
and separation from his family he
achieved a small reputation as somebody
who drank too much when he served in
California in the early 1850s he was
separated from his family for a couple
of years and he was one of these people
he's a very small man he was about five
six and a half and weighed only 130
pounds he was somebody who could imbibe
only a small amount and immediately and
visibly be the worse for wear
for doing that in the small army of
those days whose officer officer corps
was less than 5,000 that reputation was
achieved fairly quickly and it got
around fairly quickly thereafter there
are very very few recorded instances
that we know of of grant having drunk
too much
once possibly during the Vicksburg
campaign but as far as we know there is
no instance of grant as a general
officer or grant as president being the
worst for wear as a result of liquor
later in his presidency from time to
time he would take a glass of wine but
that is one of those things that sticks
and it really is an unfair label to
saddle him with
famous story here at the War College of
course is John Gordon and Joshua
Chamberlain after in the aftermath of
matters
we're grant and Lee do they know each
other before the Civil War one at number
two in the aftermath of the Civil War
could they have been friends if they had
been well that's a of course a wonderful
question and I thank you for it let me
begin by saying that my son-in-law is a
lineal descendant of one of Pickett's
brigade commanders Lewis Armistead and
this nice boy grew up in Richmond and
even as late as the 1970s and 80s he was
being told the General Grant
deliberately meant to show disrespect in
contempt for General Lee at Appomattox
by appearing in a soiled uniform in fact
General Grant was so intent on making
his appointment on time that he had
outrun his baggage and did not have a
clean uniform to wear but that is the
kind of received wisdom that still
persists in some parts of the country
and perhaps in places in the north as
well as in the south the answer to the
question is our Grant was known to Lee
but only slightly in Mexico General Lee
was 16 or 17 years older than General
Grant in 1861 when General Lee was
offered when Colonel Lee was offered the
command of the Union forces he was the
most famous and most admired officer in
the army
grant had a very healthy respect for
General Lee but it stops short of
veneration in my book I compared General
Lee's reputation in the Union Army to
that of Rommel in the British Army or of
Lord Nelson in the French Navy but that
particular reputation did not apply to
grant grant admire General Lee he looked
up to looked up to him but he did not
impute any kind of bizarre strategic
genius to Lee
they met at Appomattox they were
together for about 90 minutes General
Lee was accompanied by only
another officer grant had some of his
staff and for about ten minutes they
talked very easily and in a very
friendly manner when General Lee
recalled the two of them to the business
at hand grant asked generally what were
some of the things that he was thinking
about they had had an exchange of
letters and in effect grant granted
everything that General Lee could have
wished and when General Lee made the
additional request may the officers keep
their sidearms and take the soldiers
take their horses home and so on grants
and attitude was was frankly apologetic
I wish I had thought thought of that
before
after the war they met only once and
that was in the White House a year or
two into Grant's presidency and grant
who greatly admired Lee as he admired
all of the seniors southern generals
attempted in a in a kind of a friendly
perhaps clumsy way to uh say some
conversational familiarities you know
did the sort of baseball that kind of
talk generally was still pretty stiff
and unresponsive at that time that's
really all we know about that
relationship grant became very close
after the war to a number of General
Lee's friends Mosby became a great buddy
of grants for example Longstreet was
very close to him Joe Johnson is a
wonderful story about about Grant's
one-car train headed from Washington
down to Brandy Station and Mosby is
looking at it with 200 Confederate
cavalry and somebody says we better go
get that car and and and Mosby says no
no wait till one of their big trains
comes along
so I wish I could say that the
relationship blossomed afterwards it did
not remember that General Lee of course
died quite young at 1871 if I mean think
about this for a moment if anybody other
than Ulysses Grant or robert e lee had
been present in that little parlor in
the mcclain house what might have
happened in American history that is
literally the most important 90 minutes
in our history since 7th 1789 and these
were two men who were perfectly matched
with with the hour
yes sir
I recently read a review of a book about
Napoleon in all the denigrated maybe is
strategic prowess they talked about the
fact that what he had was something that
they sold oil even coming back I have
the feeling that the same then of course
is the most important question of all
there is no single answer I think it
varies from from soldier to Sheol to
soldier I think a you know I I think a a
private soldier let us think in terms of
the civil war a boy from Council Bluffs
who was away from home for the first
time and knows very little forms very
quickly a bond for a certain kind of
leader who he instinctively appreciates
really cares about him there is
something about that relationship that
communicated caring Ness for which
cannot be counterfeited and somehow
great generals and Colonels and majors
and people who are who are military
leaders are able to communicate that in
a way which I think results in that kind
of complete loyalty there are there are
many examples of it in military history
the most colossal barbarism in the
history of the planet is what occurred
on the Western Front in France in 1915
16 and 17 and there are many examples of
what we are talking about there
involving not only Americans but French
and English officers who are really
under the gun all the time whose
casualty rates are just astounding there
are soldiers
had what you were what you were talking
about it was just extraordinary
considering what was happening to them
but I think finally in the case of
Brandt what we have is to use Emerson's
phrase a quite authentic or Aboriginal
American an Ohio guy who you could
imagine literally in in in World War two
crouching down on Omaha Beach with a
couple of soldiers who were friends of
his who were the children of his friends
he had that feeling to him a man
completely without pretense he he just
did not really care what kind of an
impression he made he was completely
given over to the mission Americans are
at tend to be made very nervous by
people that don't talk much and grant
rarely talked but when he did talk it
was always on point yes sir
yes indeed yes
that was of course that was a great
example of a compassion that I act but
that that is basically how Civil War
battles many of them ended they did not
have the prisoner of war facilities that
we that we would imagine they had and so
they would assign paroles to each other
in other words after Shiloh where after
Vicksburg Grant paroled all of Pemberton
soldiers that is to say you give your
word not to fight again
until an arrangement is made later later
on in other words until the number is
equal out on both sides you say you
won't fight again Lee of course deserves
enormous credit for what happened at
Appomattox simply because he was told
the night before Appomattox by friends
of his this is a war that can still be
won we should talk about disbanding we
cannot join up with Joe Johnston in in
North Carolina we can disband the army
and fight as guerrillas and of course
General Lee would have no would have
none of that
yes sir
the military genius
to what extent was the appointment
performance
the the the presiding view of Lincoln as
a strategist which has been which has
been challenged in the last few years is
embodied in the title of a book called
Lincoln finds a general Lincoln is given
great credit eventually for finding a
general a military and strategic genius
and a great troop leader like Ulysses
Grant but I think more importantly
Lincoln had a very clear sense of what
the strategy had to be - for the Union
to prevail successfully he did not have
that strategy in the beginning he
evolved into it I think that Lincoln was
a I wouldn't call him a military genius
but I think his instincts were much
better than all of the book learned
generals that initially went to war in
his behalf
one of one of the great things about
World War two is that in 1941 1942 you
had this galaxy of general officers and
Navy Admirals it's almost like a laundry
list when you look at at Bradley Patton
Marshall Nimitz King Halsey Leahy there
they were in 1861 the Union had nothing
like that the first four commanders of
the Army of the Potomac all failed in
some significant way Lincoln put up with
that somehow hoping he could eventually
find a good general and he eventually
got grant so I think the the the bottom
line is he was a very good strategist he
understood the needs better than any of
his generals did but he also as Elliot
Cohen has written kept a very very sharp
very wary eye on all of his generals
including grant the American notion that
a good president will find a great
general and then leave him alone is is
really a fantasy you know if you get a
chance read this book it's a book about
them also
Churchill Abraham Lincoln and ben-gurion
and their relationships with their
senior
very illuminating on that point Abraham
Lincoln writes these famous letters to
grant in which he says my dear general
I'm so grateful to you I will give you
anything that you need to achieve the
mission and then he writes these
wonderful sentences beware of rashness
and so on but he kept a pretty close eye
on things and think about that campaign
the last campaign that began early in
May 1864 the campaign that went through
the wilderness and then down around
Richmond across the James River and
wound up and Appomattox 65,000 Union
killed and wounded out of a force
engaged of approximately 120,000 in 29
days think particularly about
Coldharbour 7,000 killed and wounded in
50 minutes at the beginning of a battle
the technology had outrun the ability of
these officers to to outwit the
technology this is I might just conclude
by saying this is a typical better than
typical discussion about grant but it is
significant also for the fact that we
are so drawn to him as a compelling
military leader that we forget that he
was the only President to serve two
consecutive terms between Andrew Jackson
and Woodrow Wilson and that he was the
single soul administrative champion of
reconstruction we think of him still
only as a as a general and a great
general thank you